[Applause]
how do you feel about andrew gillum
saying he's not gay but he is bisexual
oh did he admit it yeah because that
[ __ ] was so funny when he was found in
the hotel
with the meth heads yeah with the meth
on the ground
but uh andrew gillum he's like uh
florida he was running for governor of
florida
tenant governor or something like 2019.
what's your thought on
florida governor andrew go say
gubernatorial huh
that word [ __ ] out so hard in the
headlines the [ __ ] boys
gubernatorial accent florida
governor yeah
everybody be quiet gubernatorial
don't sound like he's asking for candies
bro yeah
we get some goobers
andrew gillum says i don't identify as
gay but i do identify as bisexual that's
funny because we identify you as gay
what do you know you know that is true
man we have no tolerance for that
bisexual [ __ ] when it comes to dudes huh
you're gay
if you're bi listen you can't be here's
a good point
you can't be bi and not gay
um so you are gay at least half gay
that's it it's a yo are you black gal
yep are you puerto rican yep
are you black yep
you can't be bi without being gay so
you're gay
now are you straight
you're half gay and half straight nope
you're both so you're
you're i think gay is like black where
if it's half and half you are that
boom like if you have black half white
so you're technically both there's a one
percent rule with games yeah
it's the percent amount of calm in your
pocket one drop
that's one one drop rule but one drop of
gum on your lips
that's a great rule actually that's the
way it should be if it's one drop of [ __ ]
then you're good so as long as you don't
get calm on you at all
you could still claim straight wait so
andrew's gay in his own cup
he comes that's gay no we did it
no no
[Applause]
[Music]
you said you launched it up and ate it
like a dog
this [ __ ] hit my face bro that's the
gayest yo that's the gays you could
possibly be
why it's one drop like for like legit
one drop
on your face it wasn't one drop it was a
lot of gas
the whole [ __ ] nut the [ __ ] damn near
scarred me i look like two-face from
batman
just sitting there on my bed like he was
on the just burning your face
melting me down acid attack get it off
of me i didn't want to open my mouth
it was maybe going to drip in it's
terrifying so
didn't you say you tasted it after mark
came in your bathroom you weren't sure
what it was you touched a little bit
with your tongue didn't you say that
that's how you figured it out
alex you disgusting
you disgust me the way that you could
turn on your friends
the way that you can turn on your
friends from the beginning of this
podcast
to the end of this podcast are you gonna
be a trainer
how could you even put a rumor out there
in the world like i would taste the
semen
i stepped on it i healed that [ __ ] like
i was at a brazilian party on the beach
but i did not taste it oh my god a
little bit no i didn't taste it i would
never touch the bottom of my bathtub i'm
a man i don't watch that [ __ ]
it's absolutely repulsive okay
say gubernatorial again [ __ ]
all right so in all seriousness we're
proud that he came out as bi even though
that [ __ ] is mad
[ __ ] yo when dudes come out his body
that's the most
[ __ ] in the world that's half measures
yo just come out as gay bro you love
dick if you have to say i'm not gay
you're probably gay you're probably
gay bro you have to say i'm not gay i'm
bi like in your
coming out probably again listen if it's
true bruh
it's true where there's smoke there's
fire and you're flaming
you're flaming real
talk we got wild fires in florida and
california
gender reveal
that's so good bro shout out to andrew
gillum watching
why they put the picture of him with his
mouth open like he about to suck
something
he couldn't find one picture with his
mouth closed bruh
not one picture yeah i know it's got
some nice lips
whoa what well were you being objective
or gay
uh bye sick dude that was [ __ ] insane
yeah you do that
all lives matter
yo you gotta come out with all bye if
andrew gillum comes out
all by his matter bruh a t-shirt yeah
i'll buy that [ __ ]
come on bro come on bro
you